welcome back to the new rock stars
debrief I'm Erik Voss joining me today
are Philip Malina hello my name is
Philip Malina you just said that and Sam
batcher hello happy to be here well guys
we're talking about some new Captain
Marvel TV footage with some exciting new
details that might be confirming some
things we've been talking about but also
we're gonna talk about some nerd movies
that have finally made it to the Oscars
top categories is an exciting time and a
Twilight Zone trailer ooh
the reboot on CD is access it's it looks
great we're gonna talk about all this
stuff
by-the-by you're listening to the
debrief it's a show that covers
everything that you need to know from
this past week in nerd news you can
listen to it on the Himalaya app also
just if you want the audio or also Apple
podcasts anywhere that you get your
podcasts it's available yes yes all
right let's get started guys we're
talking our lead story today is the
Oscars it takes place this Sunday here
in sunny Los Angeles finally Sunday
night and if you haven't been following
along with all the Oscars drama in 2019
just oh there won't be a host for the
first time in 30 years
it's gonna be an interstate ride to
their credit they tried and it did not
work I mean it didn't work out the first
time they immediately threw up their
hands there's nothing we can do we give
up I did read up on the last time it
happened like 1989 yeah it was it was
weird it was a weird one that has
weirdly Rob Lowe sings a song with Snow
White
about wanting a banger and had to
officially apologize to me okay well
here at new rock stars we're most
excited about the movies that are
actually popular here that we talked
about this you're a popular category yes
sense you know think into the
spider-verse is nominated for Best
Animated Feature it's probably gonna win
that category and black panthers
nominated for a bunch of technical
awards but it's nominee for Best Picture
yeah it's not expected to win that award
we'll get into some reasons why maybe
but it's the first superhero movie to
even be nominated and that's a very very
big deal I know Kevin Feige he's gotta
be really happy about that
first Yeah right it's a big step forward
for superhero movies in general they're
finally being recognized as pieces of
art that a ton of really
people pour years of hard work into
which is our whole thing here thesis
whenever I tell people what we do
they're like you're that Easter a
channel like no I mean yes but yeah we
also treat these things like the works
of art that they are because they get
the top people in the industry to do
every part of them like the top artists
you know Ryan Coogler it was was doing
like great films and then went and did a
Marvel movie so yes these are works of
art and these are artists who deserve to
be rewarded they can be both they can be
both yeah when we posted the news on
social media while back when Black
Panther was nominated for Best Picture
we noticed that a lot of people were
actually not 100% pleased like I guess
some people thought maybe it wasn't
deserved at that other movies deserved
it more my tough question for both of
you today does Black Panther deserve to
be nominated for Best Picture weird
answer yes win that's a different
question cuz it kinda doesn't like not
to get the semantics it doesn't quite
matter if it does or not I think at the
nomination itself is is worth it because
the movie not only brought Donbass level
it brought joy like a bra it's an
entertaining movie and it reached
audiences all across the world and like
numbers can speak for itself for like
how many how much money that movie made
but also it tackled heart like genuinely
important issues that not it like not
only like shine lights to new corners of
the MC with like well condom we get to
knowing that is it's like oh also
slavery did happen that happened and now
we need to deal with that because the
idea of Wakanda kind of it it's
immediately troubling like the idea
brought up in the movie like why didn't
you do anything and then looking back at
us Iron Man's never done anything like
that Thor is miles away from ever
dealing with any social political issue
whatsoever and it dealt with this and
our characters change our characters
actually changed in this movie I think
that what you're bringing up somebody
recently were talking apply panthan you
said something similar and somebody
called you and they're like Sam just
said that Black Panthers showed everyone
that slavery existed and your point
isn't that we didn't know this slavery
existed it's that it existed even in the
Marvel Universe like yeah and that means
that you know if we're really gonna
ground these films then you have to deal
with these harsh truths and what I think
is really interesting is that this film
so this is a reason why I think my
Panther deserves at least a lot of
credit beyond just hey it was a really
good superhero movie is that not only
did it integrate these kind of social
messages but they were a little bit more
complex than just like racism is bad
right there's like a really interesting
theme that you're kind of touching on
with if slavery was real why didn't he
do anything that a lot of people were
saying has it was a commentary for some
people he's on Barack Obama being the
first black president but not feeling
like a black president for the black
community that he just felt like just
any other president who happened to be
black why didn't you do anything why
didn't you help looked up your community
and like for Black Panther a Marvel
movie to get us thinking about these
kinds of things that alone I'm like damn
yeah I mean we definitely should be it
should be in the conversation for sure
yeah anyone who thinks that superhero
movies shouldn't be politicized I think
Stan Lee himself would take issue with
that because all those comics from back
from the 60s when he was making x-men
comics they were all meant to reflect
current events and social change that
was happening and that doesn't mean that
every every Marvel movie every superhero
movie needs to have like a very present
political message but it also means that
we should honor and respect movies that
do try to take those big swings and
answer big difficult questions and
society it's like if they tried to set
one and you know actually they kind of
did I think have a misstep with Iron Man
where it was kind of like playing around
with the idea of Middle Eastern threats
at the beginning but it it wasn't
exactly acknowledging that it was in
this post 9/11 world and and being like
authentic with that it kind of just went
with the with the way the comic books
did and I feel like that's actually
something about Black Panther improved
on the original Iron Man where it's like
this took place in our real world that
has impact on real people I think the
original Iron Man and we talked a bit
about this when Stan Lee passed the
original iron man answered an
interesting question when it came to
Americans in the worldwide frustration
with the boondoggle that was the war on
Iraq at that time and we didn't trust
institutions but we did trust the idea
of like one person who could reflect on
the mistakes he made as a war profiteer
essentially having a change of heart
when a literal change of heart in that
movie and deciding to take
responsibility for his past mistakes if
it felt like almost like a fantasy
escapism like what if we just had a
simple quick fix for what's happening in
the Middle East
what if Ironman existed in this world it
was almost like Superman as a response
to like Cold War threats like what if we
just had like one person who could like
break past politics which is a flaw a
lot of people have but Superman as if
Superman's real why does such terrible
things have happened in the same time
that he was around like don't say that
that you know a little kid from like
tripping like Superman always does these
small things like they do bend over
backwards so super mint is not getting
involved in those kinds right exactly
but I think also a lot of people would
probably say to us okay well I I think
that move move social justice movies
essentially don't deserve credit just
for that or ever so I think it's worth a
second of just what about technically
this film like the technical aspects of
what they consider for Best Picture is
it something that achieved it we were
trying acting directing choices the
technical you know camera choices and
what he's like yeah what do you guys
think of top to bottom they took they
built out a world and they didn't do it
in the way where like for example
recently you guys probably see this
mortal engines builds up this why a
post-apocalyptic world where cities run
around on wheels and I did review on
that and I hate very much did not enjoy
that movie but anywhere they see the
giant like monster and they're like what
is under and that it kind of just is
like no big cities are bad little ones
or villages and then there's some they
eat the other ones and you're like no I
can't and these are the higher class and
these are good and people will have jobs
and it's like it's kind of just like
fire hosing new with all this
information that you're like I kind of
get out of the world works because I
understand basic algebra but I don't
care and in this it really paints a
picture of like this is how there is a
monarchy but there also are elected
official officials from each of these
tribes that builds out this community
you see the lower level of it and you
see what what Conda means to the rest of
the world and you want to get understood
you get a understanding of their culture
and what each different like piece of
Wakanda what they what they look like
what they dressed like how they speak
and
what they mean to each other if they get
along if they don't get along and in
that aspect I really respect the movie
and I think it deserves recognition yeah
I think - echoes Sam's statement the
world-building is fantastic in the
production design I think when you look
at past Marvel films I can't think of
one that created like a non-existent
fictional place that felt like an actual
lipton world that you could go visit
that felt like oh this is a theme park I
want to go to like build this as a
section of Disneyland please so I can go
visit
well Conda and eat the street food that
they're selling in those scenes like
that's exactly what I'm thinking of yeah
play the music that we hear it feels
like a real authentic place that you can
reach out and touch and I think
unfortunately so many year after year
when we see the Oscars there's all these
movies that like make it in the Best
Picture category that are totally fine
films that are not movies that I feel
like I needed to see on a big screen
they're just like interesting stories
compelling narratives compelling
characters present political messages
that we all need to learn about right
now but it's like you know I grew up
with like Spielberg movies with big
special effects like I grew up with
Jurassic Park and and seeing that on the
big screen I feel like that's part of
the cinema experience so when people
like to bash movies like Avatar if
they're like oh it's all spectacle no
substance first off I think that movie
had a ton of substance but I think that
experience of going to see a huge movie
in 3d and it's one of the few 3d movies
I think was worth it James Cameron
created a new way a new visual language
I think that experienced that connection
of going to a crowded huge theatre and
seeing this all on screen and technical
mastery is all part it's as much of a
part of the cinema experience as like a
character who speaks to some current
event that's happening yeah I think the
fact they brought up avatars interesting
because you're talking about an alien
world getting as distant as as you can
from from what our reality is and yet
still having a connection to it and not
just because you had a shaved head with
a little braided ponytail but it's not
just that it's you know you relate to
this outsider story and you know same
thing with this world that was built in
and black panther I'll say a lot of what
you guys said I would say as the devil
advocate here you could technically say
is why it should get awards for
production design and and technical
categories are not best picture but I'll
say because it's not only those things
and then on top of that grade action and
directing and then also great acting for
most of the cast so to say those are all
reasons why then now you're starting
into Best Picture conversation and then
I'll just throw just straight up I think
that chadwick boseman is one of the not
weaker parts of the movie but not one of
the glowing parts for me right there I
think he's fine yeah and normally that
would be a disc like it would discounted
for me like now that's probably not
gonna be best picture contender it's the
fact that the villain of that movie made
us all walk out and go damn is he right
and we're like that's a good script
that's great acting for Michael B Jordan
now you have this complete picture that
I put argh you could be a Best Picture
also real quick isn't it about time
Kevin Feige just got an Oscar just give
a real and real creative one I mean he's
won haven't Marvel movies won yeah yeah
I am I mean sure I guess my argument is
like that guy is a billionaire maybe not
a billionaire he's a millionaire several
times over does he need this like I know
who's nominated for Best Picture isn't a
millionaire several times over I don't
know who made this is my whole thing
right like Phillip asking me question
this year especially more than other
last year's half of these movies that
are in the Best Picture category are not
good
they're C+ movies like it's blue green
more cares about these movies roma and
these are most the time it's like eight
movies that most of you didn't see but
if you do get around it going to see it
you know it ends up being an incredible
movie this time it's like these are
movies not only that people didn't see
or maybe that they did see but they suck
and it's like I hope this is a year like
we're talking I saw someone post on
online hopefully the 2020 election
believe it will be the thing that
finally destroys Facebook like I'm ready
for these institutions to be over and I
hope 2019 is the year that finally
destroys the Oscars I'm so frickin tired
of talking about these things it only
exists because Harvey Weinstein wanted a
way to make more millions of dollars and
create jobs for publicists and create
jobs for like entertainment blog or
to speculate on this crap every year
that like I don't care Black Panthers a
totally fine movie if we're talking
about game changers to get more film
cinematic art to people around the
country and to get them to recognize
things you know what Netflix has been
great about that Amazon has been great
about that we don't need this artificial
stupid award ceremony every year anyway
rant over sorry yeah I appreciate you
sharing what I mean we all know that you
would want an Oscar and your vineyard
especially if that's cuz you're dead and
they don't they're like the boss by the
way are supported by any Rock Church I
think we're we probably wrap this if I
may
everyone else the other side of the coin
is like the other Marvel movie they came
out this year that definitely deserves
an Oscar nomination I mean the wasp got
nothing this year
no Avengers infinity war they're like
technically and they put all these
stories together and all these
characters everything and it's still
getting an Oscar nomination and I
understand that you wish it had that
Best Picture nomination but when it
comes to like cultural impact I would
disagree with you but it's okay that we
have these disagreements fantastic movie
not so not so well done that it's a Best
Picture
yeah yeah and hey here you go here's the
little attaboy the CGI and Black
Panthers awful there you go there it is
because you're gonna I'll go sigh see
you typing right now you're thinking I
could smell those rhinos they were great
rhinos know they were they were okay
rhinos but you know what they put some
brine in the production design the
world-building and I didn't care that
the rhinos didn't look real yeah maybe
want some other Ryan Coogler news that
we want to this just came out there was
super excited about Ryan Coogler Space
Jam to produce he's producing this the
Space Jam too and they dropped a release
date of July 26 2021 they released a
picture of LeBron James toon squad
Jersey look at that face look at this
okay would maybe being in this he wants
to because he was posing for what he
thought would be a basketball card and
then they took his jersey had swapped it
out I think he's just mad that he has
the same billing as Lola and bucks
[Laughter]
well this is yeah it's coming out a
couple years Ryan Coogler is producing
it it's being directed by Justin Lin I'm
actually genuinely pumped yeah I'll
totally sham was my favorite movie until
yesterday there you go I would love to
but you know what gang I think it's time
for our favorite segment of the show
let's go ahead and read our trivia
question you guys know the drill hum
well this week I'm gonna be asking the
question where write the answer close as
we can the end of the question this week
oh yeah no now just only know the
question but we're gonna write your
answer down and we'll read it at the end
of the show here we go here we go there
we go hey go alright what year were the
Oscars first broadcast in color all
right that's it for us go ahead and
throw these words we put them in here
button in there and then of course the
losers got to pick from the gift of
shame boxes a delightful box Philip
broke it last week I saw no I saw real
real quick people I just want to point
something out real quick Devon got
really excited our editor Devon you know
I know he got a sound board all all set
up and through the show we've had all
kinds of segments know
last time I met someone I lost it's a
classic
all right well just I don't want I
needed to warn people because they were
gonna get startled there out of nowhere
we were probably have a lot of sounds to
like pick the next one that's a good one
but he's rivas on something else check
this out we got a few quick updates from
a previous store we talked about
recently we mentioned the Tom Hiddleston
may not actually appear as Loki in the
Disney Plus Loki show maybe just do some
voice over or something like that but
when answering an unrelated interview
question this week alan horne chairman
of walt disney studios said that we're
doing a series with tom hiddleston
playing the Loki character so hopefully
that settles yeah which was the biggest
where it was like Oh younger Loki Loki
kid to be fair there is a kid Loki in
the comics and he's adorable yeah I
would be on board with that but I'm
excited for Tom Hiddleston returning but
we also recently discussed all the
possibilities of an r-rated Black Widow
movie but now Papa aka Kevin Feige is
saying that's not going to be our
physical way that Oscar and it never was
so sneak preview into this year's what
we got wrong video duel of those videos
finally I get to be in one probably in a
lot of them well we want to take a quick
second to shout out our new best friends
over at philo they're sponsoring this
video and they have allowed us to bring
back our Walking Dead weekly breakdowns
of episodes season nines been pretty
good like season nine it's been like a
comeback in many ways for me a lot of
people are saying that the show kind of
turned around recently and unfortunate a
lot of people like don't know that yes
but it seems like they try to make it a
new jumping on point again absolutely a
new showrunner Angela King has been
doing some amazing writing and and the
episodes have been really great and you
can watch Tom part and you can watch it
on philo within seconds like Philo is
just a really really good option for
watching cable TV but without having to
do the annoying process of cable itself
you don't need any equipment to set up a
Tony parents
yeah or you don't really need contracts
it's only $20 a month and you can watch
Walking Dead on AMC of course but
they've also got a ton of channels again
Nickelodeon they got ane you can watch
better call Saul on on that on file oh
it's really like they got everything
that you need to catch up on that you
can't find other places there's like 50
other channels there's unlimited saving
so you can like DVR everything pretty
much for later and you can watch them
live as well within seconds of it coming
out and a special bonus for those of you
watching right now the first 50 new
rockstars fans to sign up at the link in
the description below will get there
first month for free free TV for a month
so it only views that link in the
description yeah
use the link in the description and
check out philo it's a great great
opportunity you're welcome Eric tell me
about so I saw the the new Captain
Marvel trailer well is a new ad for
Captain there was a promo it yeah but
fill me in what's new in it okay so
there was there's a TV promo and they're
releasing a clip of the movie there's
like a quick scene that they show they
do this usually like a week or two weeks
out of a movie they'll start to just
release stuff that starts to spoil
certain things about the movie so if you
don't wanna know anything about Captain
Marvel I suggest you you skip this this
next yeah we have been timestamps in the
section we don't want to reveal too much
but this does confirm or fall into line
with a lot of the theories that we've
been talking about with Captain Marvel
and what the story will be so in this
clip Captain Marvel is speaking to a net
benning's character and in this part of
Captain Marvel story she goes by vers
her name is Carol Danvers and when she
joins the Kree they just call her by the
last four letters of that has to do I
believe with her dog tag might get torn
off and he just severs so they call her
verse and she calls a net benning's
character intelligence and this could be
confirming that in that Benina is the
Kree supreme intelligence if you read
your Marvel comic specifically operation
galactic storm there's a whole story
that's revealed there's like a mass
murder that is connected of the Kree
race and they revealed that it is these
this AI supreme intelligence that did
this so it will force the surviving Kree
to move on and survive and evolve
so it's kind
this inhuman AI that doesn't feel
without has no empathy but it does these
things that are for the greater good but
they're actually super evil usually
she's a gigantic head in a jar Tom
really ain't on board with that
you know what Brainiac one theory that I
saw is that and that bending is looks
like you know this was some manifesting
form that the supreme intelligence has
taken to look like Carol Danvers mom
whereas really it's like kind of
shape-shifting figure and normally is a
big head but here it's like manifesting
as as your mom kind of like in the end
of contact where the aliens take the
form of it'd be a cool idea now they're
in a room that is confirmed to be a data
memory projection room this is another
thing that we talked about this could be
some kind of like x-men Danger Room
where they kind of project these things
to help you remember or help you like
learn or train brainwash or brain watch
and they talk about how the scroll are
shapeshifters dude sure everything it's
a d'Orsay that's what they talk about in
the scene but then the intelligence
shows Carol an image of a scroll
pointing a gun at her and we saw this
exact image before was in a trailer and
when that trailer current came out we
suspected that you know maybe this could
be a projected memory it's not a real
memory and we were right to doubt it
this is projected in the in the context
of this memory room and this could be
proof that carol's whole outlook on the
scroll is the results of some
brainwashing by the Kree that these two
rival military empires are trying to
brainwash people to hate each other now
I want to dive a little deeper and I'm
curious what you guys think about this
let's say the Kree aren't the good guys
they seem to be alright that Carol
thinks they are and let's say they did
brainwash Carol Danvers in some way have
they also been lying in general about
the Skrull in other words could the
scroll actually be benevolent
shapeshifters embedded in human society
to help us in some way or defend us from
this militaristic Empire of the Kree or
do we think maybe the Kree and the
scroll are both equally evil deceitful
powers that are will do anything to lie
about each other and manipulate or
corrupt this independent power in this
case earth that's cool I like that way I
like the question go quite it's a good
question let's talk about I think the
answer is the latter of they're both bad
but I like the idea of her being
brainwashed because the whole idea is
that she's trying to peace
back together who she is and so she's in
a vulnerable space where they can take
advantage of who she is in her power and
especially if the war is being fought on
her home turf getting her on the side of
the Kree to just wipe out the rest of
the scrolls make sense and usually the
scrolls and the scrolls were the ones
were basically painted as bad guys all
the time there's like one or two you
kind of throw into a story for fun
because they usually shape-shift like
the Fantastic Four so you can have some
powers in there but for the most part
they're they're the bad guys and with
the Kree it's usually like Inhumans
somewhat good guys Kree usually bad guys
as well they got they just get everybody
swept up in their business and it always
causes problems for everybody we all
have friends like that and they're the
worst yeah yeah I mean I think that that
to me whether or not that's what's gonna
happen it's what would be most
interesting it's similar what we're
talking about earlier Black Panther
where a villain that isn't just
villainous is way more interesting than
the the villain that you know doesn't
seem to have a real motivation that
anyone could actually relate to so it
not necessarily that it's a big secret
that a scroll actually good question
mark I think it could be a little bit
like know they're they're justified and
motivated because maybe they you know
are striving for survival and that's
something that makes you act out in ways
that you know you have to do whatever it
takes and I think also there's there's a
lot there
both politically but all even like
biblically like just these stories of to
not necessarily just races but like
groups that used to be pit like came
from the same source and then had some
reason or another like split up and then
they paint each other it's like the most
evil when it's like they kind of come
from the same kind of thing I wouldn't
be surprised if they're they map some of
that over those two you know it's
interesting we're now seeing a phase
into Marvel like expanding beyond like
the world not just into other planets or
other dimensions but like other races of
intelligent life like we saw it in with
the Nova Corps on Xandar and we saw it
with Asgard but now like there are other
big like armies that are in this like
constant civil war with each other with
the the Korean scroll and I you know
we're talking about the idea of
introducing a politics or art reflecting
life like you there's a comparison there
there's a
nerdy grad student thesis essay there
about how the scroll could be based on
American views of communist spies of
people with a shape-shift they talk like
Americans but they aren't Americans
they're actually trying to subvert and
destroy you and the Cree being the
American they're the Soviet view of the
Americans of these people who are just
brainwashing and forcing people to
conform and they have their own like
weird genetic in skin color conflicts
within their societies so they aren't so
high and mighty either so I like this
idea of looking at the perspective of
what's another independent planet or
race of people that are trying to be
corrupted by both sides and telling a
story from that perspective whether it
be Cuba or Vietnam or one of these other
spheres of influence that these big
global superpowers in this case the
universal superpowers we're trying to
corrupt and get to their side and
Captain Marvel sounds like from the
trailers sent it's interested in not
being part of it at all she just wants
to end this war and get earth out of it
which i think is the best way yeah I bet
there's gonna be I hope there is at
least like a moment there that can
relate to anyone who's done like
military service whatever war it's just
that idea of following orders and
identifying as a individual versus a
member of an army with a greater purpose
and if there is if it's okay to follow
orders that you don't necessarily
believe in those kind of things I have a
feeling that they'll definitely have
that moment where you know it's almost
like she throws off her badge kinda
thing yeah it's not yeah well the
directors of Captain Marvel have given a
supremely vague detail about the Stan
Lee cameo in Marvel saying that the
scene in which he appears in the movie
felt right in their words it's also been
reported at Stan Lee previously filmer
cameo for avengers endgame but no word
on any movies past that would unless
he's gonna be far from home kind of
feels appropriate game it's the final
chapter of this story these 22 movies
that started with Ironman in 2008 and in
game is the end of that era so and I I
like the way the Deadpool 2 used the
Cameo yeah mural or the way that
actually the Marvel Netflix shows that
it were just a picture in the background
always thought that was kind of sweet so
yeah for sure but we got some other news
this week Sam what have you heard not as
exciting I'll tell you gang out we knew
this day would come but that doesn't
make it any less sad especially for old
pals
cuz I really love these shows but
Netflix is officially canceled Punisher
and Jessica Jones the last of the
Netflix Marvel series we stopped iron
first at least though Jessica Jones has
a season 3 coming right down the pike
and Krysten Ritter said I am proud of
how we complete JJ's journey so
hopefully they got enough notice to wrap
that story up nice and high yeah for
this series also just putting this in
their little ad-lib I would very much
enjoy maybe like I send off like the end
of a comic series where all the
characters get to show up one more last
episode nerd alright but so tricky we
knew this was coming right we knew this
is hard felt like you're good but we
knew this was coming as daredevil iron
fist Luke Cage and defenders have all
been canceled already a long time ago
far far away but an interesting Holly
Reporter story came out this week
digging into why these shows were
canceled now there's going to get like
bring a little inside baseball here
second buckle up get your baseball very
dangerous well I'll try to keep it brief
basically Disney already owned these
shows Netflix was just licensing them
for so much money we're talking tons of
money hundreds even and now Disney some
over that arrangement so soon there will
be only one place you can find Marvel
and television and that's Disney Plus
ABC which Disney owns and they were the
one producing this show free form which
was ABC Family soak Disney owned Hulu
which Disney owns and Fox and FX which
Disney owns very soon so they're they're
just pulling it back in under Disney
which i think is kind of what what we we
know but I also read the article too and
I think the interesting thing is
apparently all the studios are doing
that they're like bringing everything
home that's why that big friend's deal
almost like didn't happen they were
taking friends off of Netflix when
everybody freaked out so right now like
Netflix has everything and Hulu kind of
has the rest sounds like pretty soon
that's all gonna be dead and everybody I
mean exclusive yeah they don't want to
end know it they don't want a license
anymore
because they can make much more money on
just keeping it in-house and then
getting people's monthly subscriptions
and bringing it all together so the
countries are closed and down their
embassies in other countries shutting
down the foreign exchange programs
bringing the troops home bringing the
kids troops home yeah I like that now a
DC Universe example keeping all the
people in one house yeah all the DC
characters no more CW shows that's a lie
bat moments coming right down the pike
but also we've mentioned on this channel
the Disney Fox deal and getting all the
Marvel stuff under one umbrella we've
talked about as a good thing and if they
reboot daredevil on Disney Plus in some
way it'll now be a lot easier
conceivably for him to show up in a
spider-man movie for example yeah you
know hopefully more people are watching
this app using it but there are well
honestly are there any negative
implications of all this centralization
creatively speaking I mean in marvel's
case it's it's a good thing these
Marvel's all about the connected
universe right you want everyone to be
able to pop up in each other's things
and the fact that like all the Disney
Marvel families all under one big tint
especially with like licensing deals
with Sony with spider-man and all those
villains and that I believe they have to
have a deal with Universal to be able to
put Hulk and things right so we'll see
if those licensing things continue right
but right now it seems to only benefit
Sony to work with marble to make
spider-man properties
I mean maybe further down the line
already we're kind of suffering like
maybe some creative fatigue that we're
seeing so many like existing IP being
adapted into movies and stories like
everything has to be based on some
existing IP oh we're making another
goosebumps movie or we're making the
stairs in a super on board and we're
like Pokemon movies and Godzilla movies
and rather than just like original
stories that you've never heard of this
character before so in that sense maybe
it pushes us further in that direction
but it doesn't leave it's not like it
makes it so that those other original
stories can't come up and exist you know
I'll say that when when I heard that
question of does it do anything negative
creatively my gut was like no actually I
think creatively is the one thing that
will flourish but then I thought about
it for another millisecond and I
realized that
there is this one issue with bringing
everything in world is that you kind of
there's a tendency at least for the
world to always have the same rules in
the same feel and so even how when
Ragnarok came out and everybody was like
whoa like that's an almost didn't feel
like a Marvel movie it was almost even
more colorful and push it even more how
that wasn't really that different from a
traditional Marvel movie compare that to
venom right venom whether you liked or
not didn't feel like a Marvel movie and
the more things that are brought under
the same umbrella and have to operate
under the same rules another good
example is a kind of blanking on the
name but the FX show legion legion right
legion does not feel like a Marvel show
that show is amazing and fascinating but
doesn't feel like something that Marvel
and Disney would produce and the more
things that are brought in house like
that well the more we're gonna get the
same flavor of the same things yeah I
think you can still have things like
Deadpool
you can still have things like Logan
produced by the Fox division of Disney's
conglomerate but now it just makes it
easier for if you want to do a story
where Reed Richards shows up you can
never read rich or show up without
having to pay some crazy weird thing and
I'd say like if we were looking at like
the like competition if you like like
when it comes to DC Aquaman built out
its own world within a world in within a
universe where it has its own rules it's
got seven kingdoms that we haven't even
touched we just ran by them with just
looking out the window we have no idea
how that world works and we still have
plenty of time to kind of explore that
and really dig into it with Wonder Woman
you have your entire Greek pantheon or
even more pantheon of gods and villains
and rogues and whatnot they can kind of
play around with so it just depends on
how they want to move forward tackling
these IPs because they could become more
uniform where it's like Iron Man worked
copy paste we keep doing that actually
do and I ain't mad about it for the most
part but you could eventually be and I
think your Aquaman example a salient but
I also think that that is an example
from a universe where the rest of the
films weren't doing well and so they
were like you know what don't feel the
need to feel connected to the existing
DC Universe now Marvel obviously is
doing well so I think it could be a
repeat of Star Wars and how to two
things one how when solo was under Lord
and Miller that it was very clear
they're like oh this doesn't feel like a
star wars movie just fire them let's get
Ron Howard on it's got to feel like a
Star Wars movie and then the same thing
in the opposite direction one last Jedi
tried to kind of like buck it a little
bit and then people are like that didn't
feel like a Star Wars movie so that's
because it's from a successful franchise
so I'm wondering it since Marvel so
successful what's gonna stop them from
saying yes please copy exactly our
formula very good point
I don't know I ate creatively speaking I
feel like there's a lot of doors there
that you could burn out pretty quick cuz
I'm feeling I can understand the
superhero fatigue now with how many
shows there are out there so I get it so
hopefully they can keep it fresh but one
last little note on this subject 1
Punisher fan in particular did take this
news they didn't take this news very
well honestly and that is Eminem he
tweeted there you go he tweeted to
Netflix that they are blowing it so who
knows maybe they'll reconsider yeah I
will be honest he does scare me that
show could've been cool if Eminem joined
because they have teamed up in the
comics before just putting it out there
it could be kind of cool yeah Marshalls
gonna write a stand letter to Netflix
but we have some other big news that
came out this week Philip about a new
reboot in the way yeah I want to tell
you guys about this because I'm very
excited about it it's my favorite story
from this week it is the twilight zone
trailer did you guys see it yes it was
amazing so good okay so it's Jordan
peels version of The Twilight Zone
just like the remake now it's not the
first time they've remade it but it's
the modern one so they released a
trailer this week it was filled actually
with a bunch of little fun Easter eggs
and references to the original AI so you
know I'm gonna point out some of those
whatever but I also I'm so excited about
it just in general that we'll talk about
it a little bit more than the other side
but first off there's a lot of clips
from the Adam Scott episode and the
episodes actually called nightmare at
30,000 feet I'm aware with the original
series nightmare 20,000 pieces probably
arguably the most famous episode so when
stars William Shatner and he's afraid of
gorillas on the wing it's a little
gremlin on the on the wing so that this
episode though I don't think is a remake
of that episode it does seem like if you
listen to the dialogue it's got its own
little tweak to it
okay I say it's working you know the the
bend of The Twilight Zone universe it
seems like it goes in a completely
different direction but Adam Scott does
look like cowboy in shiner does on the
plane sweating like salmon some sort of
breakdown or other emergency we also see
in the sand later there's that gremlin
up we can cut to a shot of that
that's the spooky guy from the wing so
obviously it's a reference to that big
boy
or is it like I mean it could be it
could be potentially meaning that this
was don't takes place in our universe
and somebody had a dog also the airport
that Adam Scott goes to is called
northern Gold Star Airways and the
original one was gold star Airways maybe
it's after a merger or something very
cool we also see if you're familiar with
a lot of these episodes there's so many
references there's that fortune telling
machine we got a picture of that that's
from the episode nick of time where they
go to a diner
yeah and they keep asking the
fortune-telling machine questions about
their future and it's eerily right it's
got a good message on it too but the
couple goes to that diner it's called
the busy bee and there's a clip of a cop
wearing a tie also that's featuring
Santa's mugshot which could be a
reference to the drunk Santa from night
of the meek there are so many references
here I do love this yeah there's a
chalkboard with the name James Embry on
it which is the name of the kid that
beat up Eric in elementary school but
also that kid was named after world war
ii pilot in the episode king nine will
not return oh and Adam Scott walks by a
wall advertising a mission to Mars and
the trailers a lot of monkeys in it
monkeys and Mars are a big part of the
twilight zone that's just a couple of my
favorite things that I noticed but if
you're a fan of the original you
probably saw a bunch of stuff too what I
actually want to talk about and I'll
stop talking it's like and I swear is
why now why did we get a twilight zone
right now
oh I mean black mare sure like Mary's
super probably I mean it's it's an
interesting time port right I it's great
that they got Jordan Peele to do it it
seems like the new career pathing he
said on after doing key and Peele was
like kind of these horror social horror
stories
feel like episode right twilight zone so
he is kind of like the Rod Serling of
our generation right now and there's
something about like just like the
moment we're in in history that feels
like we are in an alternate universe
some have called it darkest timeline
hatch the darkest timeline the name my
comedy show but it's the reason why I
chose that name for it is it feels like
all of life right now there's are there
are bad things that are happening the
world that are out of our control it
just feels like it feels fictional in a
weird way yes someone made a choice with
a ripple effect that led us to where we
are right now but also like right now
there's a lot of theories of you know
everything is fictitious
to quote Michael Moore we live in
fictitious times like it feels like
people are they don't trust any news
sources anymore and that you know
there's the whole thing of the Mandela
effect where people don't believe
history knew earlier accused me of
making up the Whoopi Goldberg was on
Star Trek there's no ego Burke was in
Star Trek or Star Trek apparently so I
think right now we are in a very
Twilight Zone arrow and it speaks to
this kind of lingering anxiety that we
all have I think that that's kind of
what I'm feeling to where I obviously
also thought black Mary was a huge hit
why not have you know the og black mare
come back but I do think that there's
something black mirrors is is kind of
myopic and it's a idea that it's about
technology and how that's gonna do must
when it's like oh we've been dooming
ourselves for a long time like way
before the internet and that's really
what the original Twilight Zone was all
about it and you know come to in the
late 50s but definitely in the in the
60s it's thriving and that's like this
may be one of the last times where
Society was that scary to be a member of
and everything felt like it was it was
shaking up and Rob Serling was was
definitely somebody who kind of like
Stan Lee was like I want to use sci-fi
and you know fantasy storytelling to
reflect themes about how we actually are
living our day-to-day lives and so
there's a lot of political commentary in
there that is hidden beneath sci-fi and
I think it's exactly what get out is I
think get out is exactly a Twilight Zone
style movie it's not about technology
being our downfall it's what if you know
the things that we're already
experiencing just were heightened if
there's a society of different social
paranoid
is a white space left over by black Mara
that has nothing to do with technology
yes I agree and I do enjoy that like it
is about like a darker time light it is
these darker stories but also it's me
make you're meant to process it too
there are plenty of stories that you
always hang on to from twilight zone
where it's they are more negative but
kind of like Sanjana Peres being that
like splash of light and rival of black
mirrors like deep dark abyss there's a
lot of Twilight Zone episodes that I
walk away from that are really near and
dear to my heart that I would like like
you're saying with kind of the way that
we're dealing with current culture it's
like take that story and figure out a
way for regular audiences or anyone
paying for CBS all access to like be
able to distill that down into finding
some peace in their personal life maybe
face life but also dive deep into the
really crazy sci-fi because I'm all on
board with it so it's so good so I want
to know what you guys think are you guys
going to get CBS all access now yeah are
you guys for this almost for Star Trek
because it was very good but what what
are some other big things that came out
this week a lot of really interesting
news and so just kind of wrapping up on
some of the more fast stuff that we
don't really have too much time to go
into contrary to earlier reports it does
sound like Margot Robbie actually is
going to be in James Gunn's Suicide
Squad too after all no it sounded like
they were recasting and yeah that's not
gonna be in there cuz he stuck as a
genie now but also we heard that army
hammer was being considered for the lead
role in the upcoming Matt Reeves about
my movie and an army hammer was like nah
no
yeah you've been good for it yeah yeah I
think everybody was like yeah I could
see that darken his hair basically he's
Batman but no he's not but maybe he will
be star wars episode 9 they announced
that the trailer for that is going to be
on endgame does anybody else think that
they're like yeah we're not gonna do
anything else other than end game until
endgame is out and then we'll search
Star Wars and just Disney will just like
control our lives
Disney would do a great job with your
life yeah I know right
so and then Captain Marvel a lot of
people were talking about how Captain
Marvel is a lot of people are thinking
it's gonna underperform cuz they're like
oh it comes out real soon and we haven't
been talking about it I is it gonna blow
it is it gonna be a disappointment
it's ticket sales of are ready surpassed
both Aquaman and Wonder Woman's
pre-sales so and those were pretty
anticipated movies so even though we're
not talking about it that much it sounds
like we're all kind of like mindlessly
like yeah yeah endgame endgame as we're
buying our tickets right sounds like
yeah you have to see the opening act of
Captain Marvel exactly yeah and before
repeat viewings hold up as much because
what made Black Panthers so much money
it's like people saw it over and over
and right if that's true for cap
tomorrow yeah it just depends on how
good it is and then another DC property
birds-of-prey I've really stunned the
picture well one was there were they
both leaks they might've both one leaks
but it shows a Margot Robbie carrying a
bunch of belongings as Harley Quinn
kinda looks like maybe she got dumped or
a baseball bat they get these childish
things out of my apartment
but maybe you got dumped by the Joker
she has to you know go sleep over at her
girl's place and then they decide to be
criminals another one shows mary
elizabeth winstead is the Huntress and
she looks badass
but she also kind of looks like she's
wearing like normcore clothes you know
like well yeah the windbreaker get a
good love that she also the chain and a
gun like you do a good but that's our in
other news segment it's super
arrey on board with this birds of prey
movie that I'm - well now comes the time
for our new rock stars debrief lightning
round
it's great this is all big build-up for
the Lightning loose lightning has no
sound that was a thunder round the
Thunder around you get sweetness
questions I'm gonna fire them at my
co-host we have to answer them as
quickly without hesitation as possible
are we ready
yeah great first question for me at
Marvel fact wants to know which MCU
character would fit best into Game of
Thrones Nick Fury because lots of people
are missing appendages Sam at Joel
Kramer's 13 was - no give John Mayer a
superhero nickname your answer should've
been Thorpe that's right it's the Wonder
Man shredder cuz he is red yeah he's
amazing if you guys haven't heard it he
did a cover of beat it with Fall Out Boy
and it's awful we don't need you to do
it sound effects he's got a guy Devin
and hipster gave me two ass before it
was cool predictions for Captain Marvel
post-credit scenes oh the beeper right
the pager goes off and Phillip back to
back questions at only alfie wants to
know what should I have for lunch
tomorrow
oh you know what don't give up on salads
give it a shot just put just even if it
takes a lot of likes like sauce on it
just to make you like it it's an entry
into salads you don't make friends with
salad you don't make friends with salad
do you call it sauce for me Davey
Brook were dad wants to know Davi be
awkward Deb I was so who's your favorite
stand-up comedian John Mulaney Sam true
scorn listen O is CGI gets to a flawless
point where it could replace actors
because it would be cheaper more
effective should they why not for me at
Becky L Ferguson was to know what team
would you be on if the Avengers were
going up against an all-star team from
the Wizarding World of Harry Potter yeah
I mean if he asked me ten years ago I
might side with the wizard in the world
but man what a weird world that's become
just whatever would you have to be an
Avenger or a child and use a spell to
make it disappear oh my god JK just too
real enough Sam and rogon's wants to
know who gets the privilege of killing
Cersei Sansa
yeah okay and Phillip true score coming
back with another one if you were to try
to introduce aliens or people to a
formally walled off country to the
modern world what movies our TV show
would you show them Batman question you
got oh man okay so one more time all
right introduce aliens are people who
are from a walled off country to the
world what movie or TV show what are you
used don't think we're so cool oh yeah
well great thank you for asking all
those questions guys keep them coming
but now we're moving on to another part
oh yes it's 15 seconds shout out now is
personally I know I said trivia was my
favorite portion but of the show but
this is actually I lied to you and you
can go and yell at me in the comments
but it's time for 15-second shadow it's
were for 15 seconds we plug or ramble
about anything that we want Sam why
don't you start thank you very much I'll
go first I would like to ramble about a
new car oh I know what it is it's a new
comic from DC Comics called Naomi and
it's about a normal girl who happens
Superman happens to in the middle of a
fight in the sky crashes down in her
study for 10 seconds flies back out and
it's the biggest thing in a small town
and somehow possibly she now can figure
out maybe she's special too maybe is she
tied to what happened
Papa it's really good if you want a new
mystery check it out great for my 15
seconds Friday March 1st will be our
second version of darkest timeline
comedy it's a nerdy showcase they do it
the first Friday of every month joining
me this month we Philip Malina coming
back we got Matt Rob from Smosh now
Smosh is back apparently Matt Rob and
Becca Scott you've seen her here at new
ruksar she does a geek and sundry stuff
plus a lot of really really funny people
Tommy Bechtold is coming Phillips also
fighting me to say the first group of
people be a lot of fun if you were there
the last month you knew how much fun and
goofy this is so it's just be a night of
nerd comedy that you can see at acne
theater in North Hollywood at 8:00 p.m.
and then follow me on Twitter for more
details and tickets and stuff in philip
i want to plug Doom Patrol but I want to
kick it to my salesman Sam thank you
it's on DC universe and it's worth the
subscription it's the wackiest wave east
wiggly a show you could ever watch it's
if you want your superheroes with a side
of sad and a little side of crazy and
all in jokes and good times and giggles
go ahead check it out
great thank you Sam thank you everybody
and let's return to the trivia question
that we asked earlier a reminder that
our punishment is a gift for shame the
wrongest answer as decided by our judges
will have to draw the task or gesture
from the gift of shame box that the
winner will say our goodbyes and
hopefully the losers motion will be
turned into a gif follow us on social
media there's motion Toby Turner all
right what was our questions oh well
first up we had a question when look
like this what year were the Oscars
first broadcast in color first I've got
FEMA right here so 1956 interesting okay
Sam said 1968 and Eric said 1965 as we
all know Price is Right rules before we
go to the oh yeah the closest without
going over closest without going over
and the answer is
1966 is the closest without going over I
should go Sam went over I went over did
you go you went over I went under you
went under I looked over so I loose I'll
take this loss with a badge of honor my
gift shame for audio listeners make sure
to follow us are at new rock shows you
can see this gift that Sam's gonna have
to do Sam what is it that you're gonna
have to do laugh at a joke but slowly
realize it's making fun of you and that
blows because I haven't recently okay
everybody thank you for watching or
listening to this week's episode of the
new rock stars debrief I would like to
thank our hosts Sam basher at Sam basher
Phillip Molina at fimo and me Eric Voss
at EA vos and a reminder that this is
available in audio form or video form so
if you're doing one you can go
re-experience it on the other video is
at youtube.com slash new rock stars and
you can get the audio anywhere that you
listen to our podcast specifically if
you use the Himalaya app you can
actually leave comments on that podcast
and it supports our show directly if you
go through Himalaya comment in tweet at
us add new rock stars like this video or
a podcast share it around subscribe to
new rock stars for deep dives and to all
the stuff that you love in the world of
nerd see you next week guys
saying that mustaches is perfect for you
[Music]